here is margavitches
who made uh 12 starts with the padres
last year two and six in san diego
this is socked high and deep out to
right center field kyle lewis charging
over to the gap kyle lewis is able to
flag it down
for route number one kyle lewis covering
a lot of ground and good communication
you can see him calling it all the way
charlie drives this ball to 30 to right
center field he's got another hitting
streak going it's now up to 12
games as he cruises into second with a
double you may
just have to bury bonds him right now
and just pass on him
i fly out to left lopes
in left field today camps underneath it
and margavitches works around the
blackmon double
no score we go to the bottom of the
first inning ryan castellani ready
making his major league debut
and that was dirty how about that for
ryan castellani
first batter faced in the big leagues
on the ground towards short there's
trevor
and a good throw across to murphy two
outs
three and two on lewis and this is a
liner right at hampson
wonderful beginning for ryan castellai
daniel murphy
leads off that's a healthy swing and a
miss up above the zone
first strikeout tonight for mark avecis
here's the pitch hung on popped up
shallow left field and toward the line
coming in as tim lopes cutting across jp
crawford crawford
calling for it jp is there and he makes
the catch and that will retire the side
a couple of scoreless innings
ryan castellani ready to work against
kyle seeger
0-1 on kyle seeger ryan castellani
center field david dahl will make the
catch one out
breaking ball evan white lifts it to
pretty deep left center field but
playable out there for hampson
and six in a row have been set down and
the debut
of ryan castellani lead off man for the
rockies
strike three call that's a good looking
pitch fastball in the inside corner
one really messed up his timing there
third strikeout four more gavin just
second
in the inning we go bottom three no
score rockies and the mariners
tim lopes starting out the bottom of the
third
that is a hard hit ball loved by mcmahon
nicely done
good play by ryan good jump on it nice
catch and then slide pop
up nothing nothing as castellani looks
to work another clean inning from the
first base side of the rubber swing and
a miss
blew it by him to retire the side one
two three for the third straight inning
so charlie now owns 18 streaks
of at least 10 games or more that he's
hit in
and charlie bounces this toward the
middle of the diamond and you know what
when you're hot you're hot
you find every hole out there and david
dahl batting now
blackman at third murphy at first base
he got him swinging
that will retire the side and what a job
by anthony mises
ryan castellani nine up and nine down
with a couple of punch outs
looking for their first base runner
tonight and that's in the air
to deep right center field but playable
charlie's out there
on the ground to mcmahon he's been busy
two down 2-2 again swing in a miss he
came inside and
tied up lewis for the strikeout his
third of the game
ryan castellani with a perfect start to
his debut
in the big leagues charlie blackman the
hottest hitter on the planet coming up
base is loaded for chuck nasty and this
ball has hit a long way
deep right field and it's off the very
top of the wall
long run now for smith two runs have
scored
and all the way from first trevor story
comes around
three run double charlie blackman
who else three nothing rockies two outs
here in the fifth
and that's solidly hit into left field
come on down
chuck nasty make it four nothing
colorado 12
up 12 down for castellani the 2-0
way inside did it hit him uh yeah it did
so the mariners have their first base
runner 3-1
and ball four pitching change is going
to occur
pretty darn memorable he did not allow a
hit that's pretty good isn't it well
done
hoffman in relief of castellani
curveball
banged off the plate hoffman will have
to hurry and got it to first in time
and that puts a man into scoring
position for trevor story
and this ball is lined toward the gap in
right center field doll will score
make it five nothing story with his
eighth rbi of the season
loaded up for nolan aronado gilboat to
the plate to the right hand hitting
oriental pitch swung on popped it up
it's playable
under the shed long right side a second
makes a one-hand catch above his head
and that will do it mariners
looking for their first hit two quick
outs
hey this will do first base knock of the
night for the mariners j.p crawford
boglebach the big left-handed batter
pitches swung on
and missed may have tipped it into the
glove of butera
here's the pitch cold strike three
blew it by him at the knees and evan
white
gets rung up kyle lewis and the mariners
down to the final strength tonight
this is on the ground to trevor across
the diamond
that is a combined one-hit shutout for
the rockies